who taught you this uh
doing time and seeing other people do it
they have life did 30 years
different ways so you know you you
perfect certain things or you do things
the way you like it
it's really hot hi my name is mario and
i'm an ex-fella hi
i'm kevin bien i'm the chef owner of
cali restaurant in los angeles
today i will be teaching the pro chef
how to make a meal i'm perfecting the
prison
ready to do this absolutely
so today we're making one of my
specialties a wet burrito so what we
have here is a styrofoam
cup double just because of hot water and
we have a bag to insert beside the cup
now open the bag up we're gonna put the
bottom part
inside there and
what else is that good yes sir this is
how you start your wet burrito
get the tortillas so you take one of the
tortillas
and you put it in half on the side right
here
like a backwards seat okay so we get a
full
circle burrito and take the other half
and make it
all the way down and they have tortillas
available in prison
yes sir you buy them every month on your
commissary if you have enough money like
two dollars a pack
so now the next thing we're going to do
is get our bowl we're going to take all
the ingredients we're going to put that
we want inside here we're going to put
this right here first
and we're going to shake it up okay so
we're going to start first with
a candle because we need the top of the
can good
to cut the meat and the chicken you take
your prison id and your brawl
you go bro uh this utensil because you
can't keep this overnight yourself
there's no everything's everything's
conserved right in the can or in a jar
yes do they use like glass jars or
plastic doors
um you can't have no glass
and chicken smells like canned tuna
we're going to take the chicken we're
going to pour this out of the bowl
all right all right and we're going to
take this and like if you have
soft fingers or that there are you
scared to get cut you take a paper towel
or napkin and you put it right here on
this part
i'm gonna use this just chop it down
this is the knife
that is the knife that's pretty clever
yes and we use that just to break the
meat down
you know and you can do this there's no
race
that's really smart okay once we're
gonna crush it up
so you don't put that in there you're
gonna keep you're gonna take your
seasoning pack and we'll put that to the
side
next we're gonna get our pork rinds and
put them in here i'll take the can i
always put it in the bag
soon trash that he sells the smaller
presents
next we're going to get one bag of chips
i'm going to hot cheetos i'm going
doritos okay
so you want to crush them up real good
next we're going to get our beans
for the hair now what kind of beans are
these these are refried beans
and then they're refried and re-dried
re-dried refried and re-dried
cereal next we're going to get our horse
and sauce
what kind of sauce is this this is
schwartz and sauce that asian sauce
and sauce excuse me yes you're probably
homestaying wrong
some people have to put these inside and
on top which i prefer
so what we do is we're going to pick
some of the yellow peppers here to give
it flavor
and we're just going to put some in here
to go inside the burrito okay
yeah what does this pronounce right
there's an at the end
hey sriracha sriracha sriracha
well a lot of people say uh police too
and it's really public i'm from long
island new york i say everything wrong
if you want to we can add meat we're
going to use a third of it
because you're going to save it for your
next meal let's go right
into there
so what i do now is i take the top of my
bowl that's already clean
and i use that as my platter try to cut
my fingers off
so when you're cooking do you have to
hide when you're doing well you just
throw it away because
they give us cane goods you are allowed
to have kingdoms so i don't understand
why we can't use this cup they don't
want to keep it in yourself they don't
keep tabs in this stuff
no they think you got this this is
something can you use this like
i don't know like because it's a weapon
like that's a key to get out of it i
think you use indian weapon but if you
can use your own chief
weapon they can't really trigger all the
stuff but you guys aren't trying to get
into fights
everybody that goes to jail is not in a
game everybody goes to jail
hurry for a traffic ticket or i didn't
pay child support
everybody that's criminal not doing
criminal things on the street in my
opinion
yeah i've been in jail with people
that's really just doing time for myself
for other people you know because i
don't want to be a snitch or i don't
want to have my family
um enjoy life in jeopardy so i just
decided not to say enough to let the
police do his job
yeah and it cost me 12 years of my life
you know yeah it's a lesson
for me not put myself in that situation
a lot of heart stories i'm
okay i'm sure put that in here okay once
we do that let's shake it up
okay so now we're gonna take the lid off
the top and we're gonna pour it
inside the hole of the burrito okay
you are ready to go now all we need now
is the hot water this is not a hot pot
that we use in prison
um that's not allowed metal is not
allowed in prison so there'll be a
plastic thing similar to this heaven
god do i have enough of this easy water
from the top of it
to the top over the top of it right
there yeah
yeah that's good that's good smells good
so we're gonna do we're gonna uh
take the slack of it like right twist it
all into the top of burrito okay
and then we're gonna tie it right
through where we're gonna try to right
here
who taught you this uh doing time
and seeing other people do it they have
life there 30 years
different ways so you know you you
perfect certain things or you do things
the way you like it
it's it's really hot so we let this stay
for all
three to five minutes some people go
longer because they like everything
because
i have a question for you do you have
any fancy foods that's even similar to
this where you have to tie it
and do it what we do in our kitchens we
um we call it souvenir it means in
french
under pressure okay which is kind of
ironic in person it's uh obviously
there's a lot of that right but what we
do is we have imagine like a vacuum
sealer
so what we do is we'll do we'll take a
bag and put maybe a chicken breast in
there
and then a little olive oil and let's
say her vacuum seal it remove all the
atmosphere
and take that bag and put it in warm
water and then slowly cooks in that warm
water
well i'll do it now right look at that
it looks good
look at it it's like a tamale yeah it's
more like a tamale technique with
steaming now we're going to take
our cheese and we're going to spread it
on top look at this
so then what you're going to do now is
you're going to take a sriracha and
you're going to
make a little we're gonna take your
other baggage you have whether it's
doritos hot cheetos so you don't spread
this on your burrito
then the last thing you do if you want
jalapenos you take the same jalapenos i
have
get some sprinkle them over the top
that's why you told me to reserve these
yes i did smart
if you want a little juice because you
like jalapeno juice you can pour this a
little juice on it get a little
twain to it you want to do that
okay and then whatever your religion is
you bless your food and voila you have
here's your wet burrito you want to open
you want to taste it
yours is outstanding you know what oh my
god that looks good right
[Music]
i still about it give me all the fish
you know i don't hate i don't have
now people what walters burritos request
different things can you
have it without the horses can you put
more beans in it can you put mayonnaise
can you put jelly i'm still eating it
right i have an interest in this is
because i love cooking
and like this is a something i would i
never had prison food before right but
this is something you use
while you have downtime and then you
kind of you can be a little more
creative
and so i learned something today for
sure i learned some of that too that you
can
that that you're really talented because
the way you're really going
from each other i like that